Evet bu ama bir akademisyenin beni bir
çoğunuz yazdım kitaplardan biliyorsunuz
Bir kız daha fazla bir kısmını da
aslında bu son YouTube yaptım
programlardan biliyorsunuzdur Ben bugün
öğrenmeyi öğrenme konsepti üzerine
konuşacağım Çünkü Hatta bir Akademisi
olarak bu alanda bir katkı
yapabileceğini düşünüyorum Bir de
değişen bir çağda yaşadığımız için bir
tarihçinin vizyonu Sizin için önemli
olduğunu düşünüyorum çünkü a tarifini
zannettiğin şey değil Az çok beni daha
çok takip edenler bunu bir tür
savaşlarda yazılması kimin hain ki olup
olmadığını karar verildiği bir ilim
değil aslında değişimin 20'dir
toplumların ve insanların değişimin
ilmidir bu değişen çok değişen Belki de
insanlık tarihi hızlı değişti çağda this
Kendimizi nasıl geliştirebiliriz şöyle
düşünün evde ekmek yapan varmı aranızda
ekmek yapma makinesi evde babam böyle
yoğurt yapıyor böyle bir çılgın bir
çağdayız
o kadar evde ekmek yapıyor yoğurt
yapıyor ancak kendi eğitimleri çok basit
bir şekilde başkalarına Yar 7 Yoğurttan
daha önemli Aslı entelektüel süreci
insanlar ve bunu bir şekilde vicdanımız
bizi rahat bıraksın diye kişisel gelişim
kitaplarına devletmiş durumdayız Bir gün
belki ben de yazarım 18 söyleyeyim
kişisel gelişim kitabı oksimoronik dur
yani birbiriyle çelişen iki şeyin yan
yana gelmesi bunları sen okumayın Çünkü
kişisel gelişim Herkes kendine ayrı özel
bir insandır kendine ait ait bir DNA sı
vardır Kendine ait bir sosyal ekonomik
ve Kuran'ı vardır Kendine ait bir
kendine ait bir ne bileyim ekonomik
statüsü vardır ülkesi vardır kültürü
vardır ve bir kitap size genel şeyler
söylemekten öteye gidemedi sürü kişisel
gelişim yani 100.000 satan bir insan 100
bin kişinin kendi kişisel gelişimini ne
yazık ki gerçekleştiren O bizim işimize
geliyor bu kolay geliyor burçlarda da
aynısı var değil mi bu Canan var mı
aranızda 2020 yılında Burcu inananlar ve
kaldırılır mı bir sosyal bilimci den
duymayan ama çok saçma bir şey bakın
büyü yok bu çok şey kabilelerde bile
büyük falan yok ya bunları
o çıkmıştı maydanoz ya falan bakarsak
antropologların sonra süresinden büyü
yok Arkadaşlarla iki de yok annem bazen
de pazara iki yolladım falan karma 3
böyle bakıyorum yani bari o taraftan
Belki bir şey gelir bu sizin modern bu
dünyanın dilinin neo-liberal üste
Kaptırdı yalanlar ve siz böyle bir
kağıda kendinizi geliştirmenize Bursa'ya
narhisar geçmiş zaten olmaz olmaz Ben
zaten o kadar geliştirmeye niye Sizinde
95/16 paylaşım buluş ve mantığı yok
Kendi kendimize gelecek Peki Neredesiniz
nereden başka gelişiyoruz bir de
üniversiteden değil mi Aslında biz geldi
gel işimize eğitimi veriyor bu eğitim
bize bunu karşılayabiliyor mu bakın
üniversite çağlarında Amerika'daki
Amerikan Çalışma Bakanlığı'nın burada
bir şey var aslında Amerika Amerika da
bugün okul çağındaki çocukların 2016'ya
göre 169 ui lise çağındaki çocuklar
üniversiteye gidiyor Ama üniversite
isteyen şeyleri Burada gördüğünüz zaman
ya aslında yüzde yirmi beş gibi bir oran
görülen işlerin 125 Amerika gibi bir
yerde bir üniversitedir riski üniversite
mezunu olmak istiyor ama biz Tamam
hastalıktan dolayı üniversiteye
gidiyorum
Bu üniversite neden ortaya çıkmıştır
ondan da bahsedeyim Universal 19
yüzyılda mühendisi subay Hekim yaratmak
için ortaya çıkmıştır ve bugün o kadar
çok meslek var ki her gün meslekte
istiyorsun üniversitede aldığımız
Amerika'da bile olsa eğitimsiz altında
yetmez üniversitenizde öğretmen öğretmek
lazım Ben kendi okudum Bilkent ya da
George long var bunu öğrendim bugün
benim sınıf arkadaşlarım içinde Mimar
var ustası çıkar mezunuyum O şeyde
düşünün Mimar var burada oturuyor kan
senaras var moda mı bitersin York moda
haftası'na çıkıyorum tanımıyorum Şair
var bir yapımcı oldu Biri Ajans sahibi
oldu ben tarihçi olduğum bakın başka bir
şey yapıyorum 7 kendini geliştiriyor
yani Üniversitesi'nde bunu öğretmeni
aslında Çünkü üniversite 13 işe
odaklanmış bu şekildedir w-1913 yılında
onbinde 7 ile 13 arasında yani BİM'de
birey ortalamaya bir kişiden biri okula
gidiyordu bugün Amerika'da yüzde yetmiş
Demek ki bütün genel toplum eğitim bir
şey dönüşmüş ama 19 metotlarıyla zaten
yapılan araştırmalarda biz onu
gösteriyor gene Amerika'da yapılmış
araştırma şunu ortaya koyuyor ki 2
ets2 sınıfı bitirmiş öğrencilere
bakıyorlar yüzde 45'ini birisi özellikle
hiç gelişmemiş Amerika'da burada
bulunuyor olacağını oranları sıra tık
daha yukarı doğru çekin dört sene
sonunda yüzde 36.6 bizim okula Gelirsen
de bir şey hemen geçiyor yani şey
yapmayın be yüzde üç kişiden biri boşuna
Gelmiş bir de Amerikan okullarında bizim
gibi imza atan filler falan yoktur yani
hakikaten böyle bütün hani ortalama
belli bir ortalama yakalanmıştır demek
Üniversitesi varsa o kadar pek bir işe
yaramıyor bir üniversite mensubu olarak
bunu söylemekten de yazık ki bu versin
paradigması değişmeli değişir de ama
sadece üniversiteyle size yetmeyeceğini
görüyorsunuz tabi Türkiye'de durum daha
da vahim Bakın bu da üniversite sayıları
var Hemen arkamda göreceksiniz 73 tane
vardı Ben girdiğimde 77 tane olmuş Ben
2006'da Amerika'ya gittiğimde sonra ben
beni bir benim yokluğumu fırsat bilip
Fenerbahçe'nin çeyrek finale çıkması
gibi a Şampiyonlar Ligi'nde 90 tane
varsa açmışlar 90 tane üniversitede
Tabii ki eğitim koşulları altyapıları
Beklediğiniz gibi olmaz bakın Bunlar
kütüphanelerinde yer alan toplam kitapla
göre özel okulların para verdiğim değil
mi Okul
iyi bakın 100101 halini alacak kitap
sayısı benim hocam yüz bini geçen 10
tane üniversite var bakın hangi kitaplar
demiyoruz sayıya yüz bini geçer 10 tane
kitabı sesi var her zaman her zaman bu
alanda birinci Bilkent Üniversitesi
tırgen öyle bakım açık ara fark 65
yüzbinde ama açık arada farklıymış
Harput 19010 kitap vardır bazen el
yazması böyle işte Sabahattin Ali Kürk
Mantolu Madonna 8.30 Yapı Kredi alalım
değil yani al
of of fourth 12 milyon cambly 8 milyon
milyon ya bize 500001 O kütüphane
bitiremiyor duk arkanda burada
arkadaşımla öyle okuyoruz okuyoruz
bitiremiyoruz Bodrum Matbaası Türkiye
hala gelememiş daha da kötü bir şey
bakın aşağıda görüyorsunuz Lokman Hekim
Üniversitesi 1231 Antalya Kepez para
veriyorsun buraya 500 artık Orada
çalışacağım Garanti olduğunu arada
söylüyorum 500 tane kitap 500 Zeynep
Mehmet Türkan Benim kızımın kitabı var
500 taneden boyama kitabı falan ama
sekiz yaşında daha kitap Bu kitabı abi
nedir Yani o anlamda göre seni
üniversitenin böyle büyük bir sorun
varsa bu sizin için yapmayacak zaten
için gittiğinizde bilmiyorsunuz işin
videosu takıldığım için gidiyorsun
Üniversitesi'nin için aldığını bilmiyor
Bir sürü insan oldu Hiçbir getirip
getirip bırakıyorlardı biz opap yani
Ders bitti gidelim bu Dolayısıyla siz
kendiniz gibi bunu yapabilirsiniz çok
değişen bir çağda yaşıyorsunuz ve artık
kendiniz internet üzerinden gelişe
bilirsiniz ama internet muhteşem bişi
kullanmasını bilene bakın Eskiden böyle
kartı tekrar vardı açıyorsunuz Ben tarih
Tabii ki falan çok gidelim Hem bebekler
sana dedi öyle oradan kitap şeyleri
elektronik değildi böyle işte bir
kitapta bulacaksınız gideceksiniz
alacaksınız 10 dakika 15 dakika sürede
böyle kütüphane kartları var tak tak tak
ta şey yapıyoruz şimdi Bunlar sinir
ettim oldu satıyorlar saflar bunları
Fakat artık metal alabileceğiniz var
dünyadaki milyonlarca kitap burada PDF
halinde var şimdi Türkiye'deki onlara
şimdi kızım alırsın parasını verip
kitaplar 300 dolar renk teorisi Bilmem
imar için çok şey değil mi tarihi
öğrenecek program yapıyorduk bir kitap
var 180 de buraya giriyorsun yüzde 50140
PDF çok ya olmazsa artık bir yerden
bulacaksın ya arkadaşından fotokopi
imkanı var falan ve bu açıkçası korsan
bisiklet ama Hayır neden hiç bir
akademisyen Yazdığından para almıyor Bu
da ayrı bir sektör başka zaman anlatırım
bas Siz burada durun çıkışta anlatacağım
altta ve roket var dünyadaki bütün
kütüphane bağlandığı Eğer Boğaziçi
Bilkent bir yerde dünyada herhangi bir
kütüphane olan eser Fidan diye geliyor
sizi 1-2 Hafta içinde ftx Getiriyorlar
bunu üniversite ödüyor ki böyle
hizmetleri de var
15 Store 75 bilim dalı 12 milyon makale
var içinde erce soruyu değilseniz
sahtesi de sayısal şöyle bir şey var
tarih tarihçilerin şöyle bir şey var THY
Havayolları ne büyük kavga etmişizdir
Benimki tane arkadaşım var Fatih'le
Gültekin İkisi de tarçınlar Londra'ya
gitmişler Londra'da böyle bir sürü
herkese açık sadece Aslında makale
çektiriyorlar sonra bunları İki baba da
koyalım thd kavga dövüş kavga çeker
Getiriyorlar buraya iki ay sonra ben de
yıllar önce Store varsa bir deste da
yeni çıkmış bunlar böyle kaldı tp35 kilo
oradan getirdikleri sirkesi artık BDP
Beni sadece şu cep telefonundan rulo
pasta oluşabilir peşimi tane kitap o
kadar 20000 alır makarna olur bunları bu
şekilde kullanabilirsiniz Eskiden böyle
büyük sözcükler vardı bir de böyle Kitap
Kokusu çok güzel geçiyor iğrenç kokuyor
Rutubet kokuyor burnunuzu çıkıyordu ben
astım oldum ve artık Wordpress var
Baksanıza katalanca diyor ya
İngilizce'de Almanca çeviri İngilizce
Hollandaca çevirisi buradan öğren öğren
oraya bu yazılı şeyi de öğrenebilirsiniz
Hatta netflix ben Fırat sesimiz duymayı
pırasa konuşurum Hatta Fransız bir tane
bu Fransız olduğunu görmedim Lütfen dil
öğrenmek istiyorsanız şunları Yabancı
dilde kullanım niye öğrendiniz yani to
bar çıkışında insanlara sormayı
öğreneceğiz İngilizce yetiyor hiç
problem değil Bakın ben mesajı şimdi
böyle kullanıyorum Fransızca kullanırsan
sonrası dublaj veriyorsa Oh ne güzel
Eskiden ben her yaz buraya Gidiyordum
ama tamam parası vardı oluyordu
gidiyorduk bir kursları işte akşam biz
kayıp Amber öğrendim gerek yok artık bak
her şeyin O kötü ne Sizler var ya da çok
kötüler benim yaklaşacak yaptım hariç o
dizileri Fransızca izleyeceğiz dublajlı
falan ancak böyle İtalyanca izleyebilir
katalanca izleyebilirsiniz izlemek
mümkün Peki biz ne izliyoruz erkekler
bir gülümseme yerleştir Ekrana bakınca
bakın daha ilginç bir şey bununla seni
de var ama ben sözelci olduğu için tam
çözemedim Belki de yoktur Eğer genelde
Google YouTube Facebook sosyal medya
arama motoru bir tane Wikipedia var o da
ödev yapmak için falan kullanılıyor
Twitter'da tartışma bir şey söylemek
için onun dışında bakın bolca
pornografik site var oyun
bu dünya Yapacak bir şey yok bakın daha
iyi geçmişi var netflix'in ortalamasına
bakar mısınız ne yazdıklarımın hepsini
dokuz dakika bunlar 14 dakika sonra ki
doğru kullanmıyoruz biz bunu kullanması
öğreneceğiz bunun için 5-6 tane tavsiye
vereceğim Aslında öyle de bitireceğim
orada bol bol zaman olmamış hızlı
konuştuğum için birincisi birincisi evet
hayır diye bir şey yoktur içeceklerin
bana söylediği gibi abi öyle mi böyle mi
Öyleyse böyle bana ihtiyacın yok Bir
soru-cevap yapıyorum Ben böyle saniyede
çıkıyorum beş kişi bilet parası verip
geliyor sonra bana soruyor bilmem ne
Tugayı'nda bilmem neydi ya sana git
Google'dan sor yorum analiz önemli
önemli olan Green tonu grinin tonlu
benim gibi bir adam sevebilirse tarihte
yi tarihçiler size bizi almış olursunuz
ikinci olarak sizi yeni zorlamaya hiçbir
şey geliştiremez size her zaman
zorlamasına dikkat edeceksiniz aynı
böyle Badıllı yapan var mı Hani
arttırırsınız ya hep beğendin toplu bir
şey çıkacak ya böyle atacak ya o yüzden
hep Çünkü bizim Çünkü sevmediğini şeyler
kadar 5 kat değil ama biraz o benim sen
çıktı Bunu herkes bir oda
şu anda bir şekilde çok sattırdı K bazen
özelde yaşlı gruplar Ya bu çok ağırdı
ama gençler demedik yaşlarda şöyle bir
şey almadım işte ya bir seviye ağır
olsun Çünkü ben okuyucu yukarı çekmek
istedim çünkü ancak böyle gelişirsin hiç
kimse bu KOSKİ okuyarak doğmadı şu
seferinden buradan anlayarak doğmadı hiç
kimse şu anlamıyor Yani bugün Damla
Bence okuyunca anlamıyor Yani böyle
olmadı Dolayısıyla bunları yapar
öğreneceksiniz çünkü Bilgi ilişkimiz
olacağız nasıl olacağız bilgi gidip
bilgi vardır Biri eski tip şeylerde
bilgiyi edilecek bir şey olarak edildi
algılanır yani sınırlı bilgi vardır
edilecek bir şeydir Özgür Tedirgin bana
dediği gibi abi küçük düşürmez bu çözüm
demişti bana tarih alanında O zaman ben
böyle kaldım 10543 Kitaplık ne iş
yapıyor Evet yani O sınavı Biz yoluyla
Ben bugün Yıldırım arkadaşına satarım bu
yanlış bir şey bu tarım toplumu
kültürüdür böyle bilgiler iş Fransız bir
şey öğrenemezsiniz kendini geliştiremez
siniz sokrat'ın dediği gibi bir şey
biliyorsam O da bilmediğimdir cildi
keşfedilecek bir şey gibi olarak
algılandığında sizi analize getirdiğini
öğrendik gece eleştirdi
o zaman daha çok öğrenirsiniz açık şey
gibi düşünün kolon gitmiş işte sende
Müdürlüğü ilk başlarda koskoca bir kısa
çıkıyor kasa bu farkında değildi hani
biz bugün gidiyoruz Dolayısıyla bilginin
böyle bir şey olduğunu ve baya bir tatlı
objesi değil insanların başına kalkmak
hava atmak için değil Bilakis oldukça
alçakgönüllü bir ilişki kurmaya zorunda
olduğu bir şey olduğunu anlarsanız ne
daha rahat öğrenirsiniz bir başka şeyden
Öndeler toplu bir sürü yalan söyle
Bunlardan biri de kolay yol hani böyle
kolay yolu istiyoruz ya mesela ciddi
manada hocam 78 Yılmaz konuşuyoruz
çalışarak konuşuyorum değil mi İlk başta
onu şey yapmasın var bunu ama herkes
böyle bir şey vermem herkes böyle palet
balerin Olmak İster bak ne kadar güzel
gözüküyorlar Ama kimse böyle ayaklara
sahip olmak istemiyor aslında bütün
probleminiz var herkes öyle herkes
bilmek istiyor kimse öğrenmek istemiyor
bilmek ev yapacaksın balerin kim yol Ya
kızım Alev Alev Alev Alev işte bak
ayaklar böyle olacak Yani bu da işi şeyi
akademisyenliği de şey var Mesela ben
hiç susmuyorum sürekli şey yapıyorum Ama
artık ben odaya falan kitli
Bu arada böyle arkadaşlar devrek'e neydi
ve zayıflama çayları değil mi o iyiyim
zayıflama çayları çok basit bir mantığı
var ilk başta bağırsağı temizlediğini
750 gram veriyorsun dolayı Arkadaşlar
para vermeyin böyle şeyleri dolayı aynı
şekilde de nasıl kolay zayıflamıyor sana
nasıl her şey kelle paçayla çözülmüyor
sa ne güzeldir sen bakma kelle paça için
of bizler çok iyi falan olmuyor ağabey
değil yani bunu bir Tıpkı olmaya gerek
yok anlıyorsun zaten motorinden şey
olmuyor hepimiz Açıkçası da
Ne alaka nasılsın
bir şey olmayayım
abone ol
Ben de yersin orada yağışta
bilgisayardan bu kadar önemli diyor
Böyle bir şey yok arkadaşlar mause
kasetten dili öğrenilmiyor nopainnogain
diye bir şey vardır acı olmadan Kazan
çok denizdeki böyle her şey Sizin
elinize direkt gelmiyor bunun taklidini
yapabilirsiniz nasıl Öyleyse burnumuzu
ağzımızı heryeri yaptırabilir kültürlü
gözükebilir Siz o Türkiye'de baktığınız
zaman dünyada hiç kimsenin bilmediği
kadar filozofun ismini bilen bir sürü
insan gördüm ortalama nitelikler
sevgimize belli Dolayısıyla Biz bilgiyle
yararcı hava atmak Marmaris olmak üzere
değil böyle aynı şekilde çalışarak bizi
kendimizi geliştireceğini Yani dışarıya
göstermek için değil kendimi zaten daha
iyi bireyler daha iyi bir anne daha iyi
bir baba daha iyi çalışan dair evlat
dahi bir mesleğimiz insan yapan insan
haline getirecek bir şeymiş gibi olursa
şey kurarız bir başka son yalanlıyor
verdin Aslında sen de yaparsın Hayır
arkadaşlar sen de yapamazsın inanmak
başarmanın yarısıdır ne yazık ki böyle
bir şey yok inanmak başarmanın yarısı
falan değildi inanmak başarmanın ön
koşuldur Çünkü zaten başarılı değil mi
kaderini eline aldığı elinde birçok şey
al
bu ama kadar Bunlardan biri değildir
arkadaşlar yapabilecek bir şey yok
ya ben niye böyle yaptın içim inanarak
başaramazsınız her kadın güzeldir Her
kadın güzeldir çirkin kadın güzel olur
bunlar öyle bir şeyler yani benim Ben
şimdi sabaha çok para genel Çünkü ben de
beraber gelir daha çok kazanıyor Öyle
bakarsın Yani para kazanır o da budur
başarının tanımı başkasının yapamadığını
yapmakta basın yapımı yaptığı yapmanız
için de böyle bu yalanlardan kendinizi
arındırmanın lazım yeteneğinize göre iş
seçin dolusuna üç tane şey söyleyeceğim
bir şey öğrenmek istiyorsanız ne kadar
biliyorsunuz önce o Nereden geliyorsunuz
yani FIFA tarihi Resul dayı Sosyolojiden
görüşürüz meclisten mi geliyorsun iki ne
kadar öğrenmeniz lazım sunumu yapacaksın
Kitaplığı yazacaksınız Yoksa bir insana
bir tavsiyem vereceksiniz yine efendime
söyleyeyim yoksa zevkiniz için okula
bunu bilmemiz lazım Bunu da dışında 3.
ne kadar zamanınız var Çocuk geliyor
bana ya o elli yaşında adama bu çocuğa
Roma tarihi çalışmak için zaten
göreceğim yok Ben öğrendim unuttum
üretici Sen Roma tarihi 50 yaşından ile
çalışacak ya okumak merak ediyorum diye
Roma tarihçilerine stroması anca Latince
bilir
da gerek yok Gerek olmayan şeylerle
uğraşıp iyi bir satıcı ile girmezsek
bilgi kendimizi geliştirmeyi ve son
tavsiyem Ve bu çok önemli bir şey abi
targon el ortaya çıktı kez aptallık
çağında olduğumuzu söylüyor gene
karadibek başka bir şey söyle insanların
akıllı gözükmeye uğraşı onları
aptallaştırıyor hayatta en çok duyduğum
Sorun ne biliyor musun Biliyor musunuz
Bir bıyıklı ne zaman bıraktım soru ama
iki numaralı soru a bunu da mı
bilmiyorsun adam rahat en çok büyük
cahillik en çok sıkıntı cahili koşu
soralım ona sorarım bu ne sorunu çekeyim
ben ve genelde hiç bir soru sormayan
benim tanıdığım herkes her şeyi
biliyormuş gibi oluyor en çok sorulan
sonra bunu da bilmiyorsun sosis a****
gözükmek istemiyor ve bu merak onlara
aptallaştırıyor sormadığı için kendini
geliştirmiyor ve hiç bir zaman unutmayız
sormayan öğrenemez sormaktan korkmayın
çalışmaktan çabalamaktan çekinmeyin ve
belediye düşünebilir Çok teşekkür ederim
üçüncü bir şey çünkü bulamadım ve ama
yapacak herşeyi olmadı Çok teşekkürler
üzülme
abone ol